today we're going to talk about how to
get rid of asthma symptoms
okay it's a very very
powerful and exciting technique that
you're going to learn if you have asthma
but it can also be good for people that
are in stress people that have hay fever
people who snore people who have sleep
apnea
and even people that cannot sleep
now this is based on this book right
here called close your mouth developed
by professor buteyko it's called the
buteyko breathing method extremely
powerful if you have asthma now before i
get into it i need to give you a little
background
on how this works simply because it's
very counter-intuitive so you have to
kind of understand some basics so if we
take a healthy normal person versus an
asthmatic person
the average breaths per minute in a
normal person is between like 10 and 12
breaths per minute but an asthmatic is
15 to 20 breaths per minute okay so
they're breathing more frequently each
breath of a normal person as far as
quantity of air is about 500 milliliters
okay compare that to an asthmatic it's
700 milliliters to 1 liter of air
and in a normal healthy person the
volume of air per minute is about 5 to 6
liters
compared to an asthmatic it's 10 to 15
liters of air and that's the volume of
air per minute so you can see an
asthmatic is consuming a lot more air
than a normal healthy person
now here's the counter-intuitive part
co2
okay
is normally considered a waste gas right
we breathe it out we try to get rid of
it but co2
is actually more important than oxygen
okay
or shall i say it's just as important
but if you have asthma it's actually
more important now to understand why you
have to understand
this
it's called the bohr effect the bohr
effect is an observation
by i think it was a dr bohr that the
binding of oxygen in your blood okay in
the hemoglobin is dependent on
co2 carbon dioxide
okay in other words co2 cannot stick to
hemoglobin in your blood it can't be
carried it can't go into the blood
unless you have enough
co2 now that's a pretty interesting
piece of data that i didn't know until
recently all right so here's the next
piece of the puzzle
breathing a volume of air greater than
normal does not increase the amount of
oxygen in your blood
now that's another counterintuitive
piece of data so when you're trying to
breathe more than normal you're not
actually getting more air into the blood
and the blood is already saturated at a
saturation rate of between 90 and 98
so when you're trying to breathe in more
air than normal you are actually
lowering
the co2 and remember we talked about
this you lower co2 and then the oxygen
cannot bind in the blood and this is why
when people hyperventilate okay they
actually pass out because they're
getting less oxygen why
because they're getting less co2 to be
able to bind the oxygen to the
hemoglobin
so the more air
the less oxygen is delivered all right
so you got that concept
let it sink in
if it's not sinking in
watch this part again because it's going
to be important for this next part and
one little side note
when you breathe
roughly about 75 of the oxygen that's in
the air that you breathe is exhaled when
you're breathing let's go into the next
part
all right so the less co2 you have the
more the airways are constricted so if
you're an asthmatic and you just can't
get enough air realize you don't have
enough co2
so co2
the so-called waste gas
actually relaxes your smooth muscle okay
in your lungs it relaxes your lungs it
actually helps you breathe so what is
the real problem with asthma
over breathing
okay
what do you normally see in an asthmatic
they're usually trying to get more air
right they're suffocating they're
constantly trying to get more air and
when they over breathe they lock up the
oxygen ability to bind in the hemoglobin
so it makes it worse okay and this also
would make sense too if you look at it
from the viewpoint of stress when you're
stressed you're trying to breathe more
you're trying to get more air right and
where are you breathing from your lungs
your chest
you're breathing like this and all that
extra breathing is locking up and
shutting down your oxygen
and you're using more of your
sympathetic nervous system it's called
the flight or fight you're not in a calm
state now this relates to a quick story
a while ago i went to lunch with a
patient i had a long time ago and we
were at lunch we were talking and
all of a sudden she was like
i can't breathe i can't breathe some
food got stuck her throat and i'm like
okay how do i do the heimlich maneuver
so i had her get up and i started to do
it and it didn't work
and everyone was sitting around they
weren't really helping and they were
just kind of just they're kind of like i
was surprised that someone didn't call
9-1-1 but i started getting nervous
because it wasn't working so i saw her
face turning red and she's like what am
i going to do
and luckily i came up with this idea i
said
okay calm down just relax i had her sit
in a chair i started to kind of massage
her neck and just don't try to fight it
just relax and then bam she started to
breathe again okay why because when
you're in flight or fight mode when
you're in stress mode everything gets
constricted okay including your lungs
including your throat so if you're an
asthmatic you definitely want to relax
but the more over breathing you do the
less you're going to get oxygen into the
blood the more you're gonna have things
like sleep apnea asthma hay fever and
even nasal congestion
so
this is the technique okay
and it's really simple
instead of breathing fast you want to
start slowing down your breath okay
instead of you know trying to sigh and
get more oxygen okay or gasp for air you
want to just start breathing in a very
regular way
and a very gentle way
through your nose
not your mouth okay and some people find
it very helpful to just put some tape on
their mouth when they go to sleep at
night so you can start practicing
breathing through their nose so you
really want to get to a state where your
breathing is very silent it's very soft
not so it's noticeable so even if you're
laying down trying to rest and you can
hear yourself breathing you don't want
that you want to breathe so it's
completely quiet and very very soft very
gentle
so the air that's coming through your
nose is very very light and it's coming
out through the nose very very light
you don't want to breathe with your
upper chest you want to focus on
breathing through the stomach okay so
you can pull your diaphragm down
the diaphragm is innervated by the vagus
nerve which is all
parasympathetic nerve control
so
the autonomic nervous system is both
voluntary and involuntary in other words
you can control
your autonomic nervous system
through this type of breathing you can
take yourself out of this sympathetic
overdrive or flight or fight mode just
by
calming down your breath
focusing on the breath coming through
your sinuses
very slowly and gently and coming back
into your sinuses and no longer
breathing through your chest breathing
through your stomach now the first thing
you want to do before you do anything is
you want to measure how long you can
hold your breath okay comfortably so
this is called the comfortable breath
hold time or cp
all right
now if you can only hold your breath
10 seconds or less
then you have a severe situation okay
you have severe
asthma but if you can hold your breath
between 11 and 20 seconds
it's not as severe but you're going to
probably have many symptoms related to
asthma
if you can hold your breath between 21
and 40 seconds
you're going to have less symptoms
and if you can hold your breath over 40
seconds
without that strong urge you're going to
have absolutely no symptoms related to
asthma so the symptoms of asthma are
directly related to your ability to hold
your breath
comfortably
so guess what the goal is to get at this
level right here and to be able to
maintain that for at least six months to
really make sure that your condition is
in remission of course we can never say
cure but we can say it's in remission so
the question is is holding your breath
the actual technique no it's just an
indicator or a tool that you can use to
figure out if you're progressing okay or
not right this is the exercise right
here you're just actively
slowing your breath down you're
breathing through your nose
you're breathing through your diaphragm
and you are when you're resting at night
you're having the air go in very slowly
through the sinuses and out through the
nose so as you monitor this cp or
comfortable breath hold time
you're going to notice that you're going
to be able to hold your breath longer
and longer and for every increase of 5
seconds you're just going to feel better
and better and better so what is this
technique doing it's increasing the
concentration of co2
and something else
when you breathe very very gently
through your sinuses you're also
increasing another very therapeutic
gas called nitric oxide which relaxes
the sinuses okay and you're going to
find when you do this that your sinuses
are going to start to open up they're
going to relax you're going to breathe
better through your sinuses and when you
check this breathing whole time where
you're holding your breath
i recommend that you just plug your nose
so that way it's easier to hold your
breath so very simply
start breathing through your nose
make sure your breathing is very gentle
and very calm never hear your breath
when you're resting make it very very
silent
slow your breath down as much as
possible
because you're going to allow the co2 to
help the oxygen bind with your
hemoglobin and use the diaphragm to help
you breathe not your chest you can even
put your hand on your chest and your
stomach
to practice that as well now the other
really cool thing about this is that
you're going to find your stress level
is going to dramatically decrease your
ability to sleep is going to greatly
improve and everything connected with
that is going to improve as well so i'll
put some more information about videos
you could watch to get more data on this
as well as a link to the book but if you
haven't seen my acupressure technique
on how to extract stress from your body
that would be the next step check it out
right here
you